[音楽]
今日は外れ社長です皆さん一強いですよね
避難ても似つかでよく使われるものなんですよ料理をする時も日も頭のボカシないです
けどさっき日をする時もし羽するのも低い
もうどこを見ても日常には日があふれています是非って本当に危険であの熱いんですよ
厄年ていますという声で今回はこちらこれが玉これが低
したうマギー棒が服を買ってきましたこの防火服何かといいますとなんか
期から身を守るらしいんですよ日を防ぐとかえって防火服なんでもこれを被ってるとも
僕は多分厄年ないですよね
もうすごいうまい米動いくれなくなって5位なんかすごいところは完全に何かも居な
そう思えるよとかなさそうです
ナンバー2って書いてありますねなんかなんとかせ手に入れたんですけど火事の時に
立つ気に入ったりする時のあの日からみを防ぐ服なんでこれを相手には多分どんな日の
中でも無事に行けるんじゃないかという気がしますねちょっと着てみましょう
これ
ten
はもうすぐ考え方へ超固い
うわぁきつねバトルそんなに首が長くないんだよ
[音楽]
抹茶オレそんないくガーソン難易度高くないんだけど
おます
もうすごいすごい配牌というゲー
留学ってみましたいやーすごいですね
これなら食べての中でも僕は夫人に入れると思いますすげーがちゃうだなんて今回です
ねちょっと
防火服ってるッ
本当に燃えないのいやもうイライラしてます隙間が一つもないこれだけ酢蓮服なんです
けども本当に燃えないのかどうかちょっと本当にちゃんと検証していきたいと思います
ねもう行ったら困るんですけどどんな感じなんだろうって日の中にこれで言ったらどう
いう感じになるのかなっていうのをちょっとで本当に試してみようと思いますちょっと
花火をたくさん買いました花火よああああ額でも花火たついから綺麗なんです
生田バッチってなるんで法学を切ることによって熱くなってきれいな肌とアベルことが
できるんじゃないかという声花火前になるという素敵な体型をしていこうと思います
やっていこうと思います
ぞ
[音楽]
ねっだいぶたつ通るシャベルとします
wh
前2つ
ん
皆さん
マネしないでくださいマネー絶対ないと思うんですけど者の応援許可をとって安全を
確保した上で
行っております男児で今危険なので真似はしないでください
[音楽]
dee
はい強調するなどみろ
を受けてみたいと思います
ああああああ
また本当に強い例えばどうぞ8倍いや大丈夫なんでしょ
家からも者さんこれになっておる
思えたらー
赤いを負った
ブルーブルー
い
par
ああああああ
car
ええええええ
[音楽]
[拍手]
car
あっえっ
[音楽]
me
teal
car
ana あああっ